this
is star talk i'm your host neil degrasse
tyson your personal astrophysicist
and today's topic is proving
einstein right chuck i needed you for
this one because
yeah yeah man you're the man i don't
know how you need me because i
i never knew einstein was wrong
so i'm trying to figure out where
where's the controversy where's the
controversy
well to talk about that controversy i'm
bringing
a friend and long time colleague jim
gates jim
welcome to star talk well neil it's good
to be back in the presence of a star
oh james please it's okay
thank you thank you i appreciate you
i will leave one that one at that
[Laughter]
so jim you've been at this for a long
time well you've been an einstein fan
for sure but a theoretical physicist and
your director for the
center for theoretical physics at brown
university providence rhode island
and uh that's a title how long you've
been doing that so
uh when i was 66 neil uh i was recruited
from the university of maryland to brown
i went around telling my friends uh
asking friends
why why do you think they want an old
car no it's not the age it's the mileage
okay
one of my friends said jim you're not an
old car you're an antique car
oh oh there you go the preservable
antiques they they hold their value
i'm gonna go one better than your friend
james you are vintage my friend
you're a vintage vintage is vintage
gives you even more money than antiques
well i i i switched after 33 years at my
previous uh
university it came here and where was
the previous university
university of maryland college park wow
and do they
are you still on speaking terms because
i i would be
kind of angry after 33 years that you
just up and leave me just leave our
marriage after 33 years
well i don't know if the marriage is the
right analysis
[Laughter]
but right in the independent of debating
that particularly
we did we did part of determined
in fact i'm an emeritus professor there
and
as an emeritus professor i have taught
uh
two consecutive years courses on public
policy
nice evening courses yep so i'm in good
terms
so if i remember correctly you were on
obama's um
uh advisory council for science and
technology right
that's exactly right neil i served seven
years
on the president's council advisors on
science and technology
now pcas that's right that's right so
um but you weren't in the current
administration they they didn't invite
you to back in there huh
i thought we were gonna try to keep okay
i just wanna
that's all right i uh i was invited to
be on this current administration's
advisory council on
writing jokes about technology
there you go um so if you're director of
the center that's not necessarily an
academic title that's
that's a job title so you're also
professor of physics
indeed i i'm an adult professor here at
brown university the
endowment is before i'm the so-called
ford professor
of physics i'm also an affiliate
mathematics uh
professor and on top of that i'm a
faculty fellow at the
watson uh institute for public affairs
and international affairs
wow excellent excellent okay nice stuff
so you're
like we should we should bring you back
for seven other excuses
seven other reasons i forget the
theoretical physics we've got some
policy we gotta figure out here yeah
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
structure this program we're going to
spend the first
segment just you know talking about why
was
einstein proved right or why did he need
to be proved right
and then we'll go to q and a we go to go
to our cosmic queries
and uh chuck you've got customer queries
for some i have two and three
i have the questions right here and i
have to say these are some
man people are excited that you're here
uh professor they are excited
we've got we got some great questions
there's no one that triggers more
questions than einstein
and relativity and we got the man for it
well i would say einstein relativity and
tyson
and what and tyson the most
okay right on
all right so so jim you published a book
in 2019
called proving einstein right and let me
get the full title of the daring
expeditions
that changed how we look at the universe
sure
and um do you have a co-author who was
that i do have a
wonderful co-author her name is kathy
pelletier
she lives in alagosh maine which is just
a
right across walking to canada and
this book is not what people expected
usually
you know neil your first book as i
recall was partly autobiographical
right well that was one of my first but
my fourth book yeah okay four
so what i wanted to do with this was to
do something i had
never seen done before with physicists
usually people talk about the wonder and
the majesty of looking at nature and
their struggle and what have you
but what i wanted to do and i had wanted
to do this for a decade
is to write a book about the interior
lives of the people who
do the science and so this book is
actually dedicated to eight astronomers
and albert einstein
and we yes we tell the scientific story
but what we really want to do is get
inside of their heads and tell the story
of what they were
feeling as they went through this almost
decade-long struggle
so the book surprises people okay so the
book is published in 2019
and if i remember my history that's
basically the centennial
of this big experiment that showed that
einstein was right
that's right but but let me back up a
little bit so
um most people i mean physicists
know einstein for both for many things
of course but for special relativity and
general relativity i think uh often when
people
think of einstein they they think of the
effects of sort of ordinary relativity
like time dilations and
this sort of thing so that would all
happen in in 1905.
that's correct so why if that's all
happened and it worked and it was
you know it was it was smoking effective
it explaining our understanding of the
universe
why didn't everybody say yeah einstein's
the man why did it have to wait another
10 years for them to prove some other
thing that he
did so let me talk about einstein 1905
and thank you for giving me this opening
as you know neil
in 2005 there was this so-called
einstein year of physics and there were
celebrations all the world
i gave 37 talks on six continents on
einstein in that years well i thought
there were only five continents
[Laughter]
no i guess there were seven i get my
numbers i yeah i thank you
i you left out antarctica yeah okay that
because that's the one i've never been
to
yeah yeah but the penguins will will
welcome you with open arms
and happy feet yes but the point was yes
you're right neil in 1905 he came up
with some amazing things about space and
time and how they bend and warp and what
have you
but do you know that in 1907 he was
still in the patent office
people think that as soon as he came up
with his wonderful theories the world
beat a path to his door saying hosea
hosea you know whatever but no
no no that's not what happened it's
hosanna
jose yeah jose is the prophet but
hosanna
hosanna is the praise but we knew what
you meant
well this is what happens when you go
off script guys
no no but you're right uh but the point
was that
he did this great piece work but it took
two years for the physics community to
recognize what he had done
wow while he was in that patent office
still trying to figure out how to get a
job as a physics professor
he looked out the window one day and he
saw some workmen on the roof
and he had this uh sort of story coming
to him
that if the guy one of the guys fell he
wouldn't feel his weight and so
that started einstein thinking about
gravity
he's thinking of the death of someone
working on a roof next door i did not
know this
well not the actual death but right a
process that would lead to it
yeah it's just just his fault to
imminent death
okay i did know einstein had this morbid
side of him
yes and so let me just say i totally get
it because i think about the death of
the guy that blows that leaf blower
outside my bedroom window every saturday
morning so
and so i started start thinking about
gravity and
by so this is like an in fact he calls
this the happiest thought of his life
wait so so wait so jim this is like
newton's apple moment
yeah where he sees the apple falling and
then he sees the moon and then there's a
there's a there's a eureka moment in
there and that's what happened with
einstein in 1907.
so the thing is curious about einstein
is although people think about him as a
mathematical genius
every time he did something he actually
had to learn more mathematics so he
didn't actually have the mathematics to
realize
what his intuition was and he didn't get
it right
until 1915 or
60. you know jim that happens to me all
the time i have thoughts i have to
invent new math to
you know that's just that's just a thing
well you know some of us actually do
that
another another whole story and i'll
tell you about that one later
but uh anyhow so he had this idea that
took him
almost a decade to get it down to the
mathematics
and when he finished it it was the
theory of general relativity it's the
piece of thing that tells us that there
was a big bang
it's the piece of mathematics that lets
us know we live in a universe
that is 13.8 billion years old
and so that came from that 1917 epiphany
wow i mean 1907 1907
right right right right now now remember
it's all math
it's all mad so if it's all math
how do you know he got it right right
just because
the math works doesn't mean it has to
correspond to any objective reality
exactly and so when he finally
gets his discussion together he in fact
even before he gets the right answer he
starts talking about
he starts giving talks about it and so
very early on astronomers realize
well he realizes first that astronomers
would be
critical to try to prove that his math
is actually as you said
neil something that happens in the real
world and he begins it by talking to
this
uh german astronomer named irvine
findlay feundlich god
i never heard it again no but no one's
ever heard okay
but it's if i'd ever met someone named
irving
finley foreign yes i'd remember that i
think i'm pretty sure
well well i have said uh for your
program i sent some photographs of all
the people that we're talking about
that's the first guy that einstein
starts talking to seriously as you know
i have a way to prove my man
and he first started saying if you look
at starlights
could you show that starlight bends when
it passes near uh
near jupiter and the astronomer says you
know nah
that doesn't quite work then he starts
asking questions about well suppose we
were looking at the night sky
uh the in the morning or uh during the
early morning or late afternoon could we
see bending starlight
around perhaps venus or something the
guy says you know the astronomers come
back no no that won't work
and so finally by this set of
discussions with foreign he hits upon
the idea
that if you could watch starlight during
an eclipse
right you might be able to see the light
being bent
by the sun because you can't otherwise
see a star in broad daylight
exactly so it's very special
circumstance
so that's towards the race okay so
this bending of starlight would have
been the first
uh experimental verification of his
general theory of relativity
yes and okay and so so now
so what year did that happen was that
come this is this is this these
conversations around
uh 1912 or so that he starts telling
other people about society
okay and that's how you get the
creativity of other people to help you
figure out how to make it work bingo and
that's what our book is about is
it's about the other people it's not
really about einstein
okay so what's all this we hear about
his wife possibly being a big engine
to his creativity a lot of people have
well this is one book uh my sex wife i
think is the title
um there are a lot of people who have
posited that as as
having been important but from my
reading of the history
she was certainly his partner as he was
working through
uh in bern as a poor
uh patent examiner trying to do physics
she was certainly a partner
to burn this city in germany in
switzerland
switzerland excuse me right right uh he
was so she's certain was his partner
there
but in the actual settling of
the special theory of relativity from
and i've i've read over a dozen books
trying to get this straight in my own
head
the preponderance of evidence is that he
worked it out
with the friend of his uh
on a train on a tram ride thinking about
the clock tower in the city of burns
so i mean it's a fantastic story
[Laughter]
so what you're saying here jim is had
einstein been a loner and not traveled
anywhere he wouldn't come up with any of
his ideas
how much life exposure is the right
amount
to fully realize your
your your creativity that can be
expressed
i tell people all the time that being a
scientist means that you swim
in a sea of information and that
information comes from your colleagues
so you cannot be i mean i know the the
archetype
stereotype view is that as a scientist
you go off in the corner and you sort of
think big thoughts but that's not what
actually happens i've lived this life
for
almost for over 30 years and you are
constantly in conversation with your
colleagues
and you use them to hone and to refine
your thoughts
and distill your thoughts and curate
your thoughts so jim the active word
there is that you are
swimming in these influences not
drowning in the influence i was going to
say yeah
yeah so that's where that's why where i
with cathy pelletier we wanted to talk
about these people that
basically were using what einstein
inspired them to
but to swim towards this discovery of
whether
his math was an accurate description of
nature wow
do you think einstein had any doubts
about whether
it was all true from my reading no
um he sort of said you know he sort of
says things like
if if the theory of general relativity
uh had failed to
uh receive experimental and observation
support
that he would have felt sorry for the
good lord because that was a really
brilliant idea right
which is which is kind of say a kind of
way of saying like i'm smarter than god
so it definitely says that yeah no it
doesn't
really no no jim jim you're lying jim no
i'm not lying
if you read a lot about einstein you
find out he's a very very complicated
character
and with resp and if chuck said you
brought up the issue of god
okay and and you did bring it up i did
yeah i mean to me when somebody says
that statement it kind of sounds like
you know i'm smarter than god i don't
know but see einstein's
although you can interpret that
statement that way that's not really
what einstein felt because
okay in fact uh he talks also about the
illimitable
spirit that is a spirit without
limits so it's clear that if you can use
a phrase like that
you're not putting yourself above such
an entity
okay all right that's a very good point
he didn't use that phrase
in that sentence though but okay not in
that sentence
in that moment he felt badass is all i'm
saying yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's not yeah
because it because it is you know um jim
before we go into the
second segment and solicit our our
cosmic queries
just give me a minute or two i know it
should be
hours or two but give me a minute or two
on the idea that
math is just something we invented as
humans
yeah and and it works what's up with
that
you know there's no reason that it
should work at all you know
neil this is one of the most this is the
only piece of magic
that i've ever experienced and seen in
reality i love
that except i'd love that it's magic
it's it's a piece of magic but it
happens to be a part of our reality
i don't know of any other form of magic
for which i can say this
and this is human-created magic
we create something and it magically
describes reality
and enables you to predict and
understand
and extend yeah it acts like a third eye
for those of us who are scientists it
lets us see things
that are not seeable otherwise i was
i made a presentation at the new york
academy of sciences
about three years ago two years ago and
it's precisely on this point of the
magic ability of mathematics it's an
hour-long
interview so i'm not going to bore you
with it but i would was it on youtube or
something or is it
yeah it's available on youtube
absolutely well forgive me i'll go find
it i'm going to find it
okay the new york academy of science is
a a long venerated institution
absolutely and i was there with margaret
where time and we discussed this
magical thing this thing about
mathematics and in the at the end of the
day what i
one of the things i said i said about it
is that mathematics as
people like me use it it's
the only human language that we know
accurately allows us to describe nature
however
other conscious any other conscious
being
that could produce mathematics will have
access to this knowledge
so hence the idea that if we meet up
with aliens we might start with the
symbolic
representation of what is and is not
sure and math could be the only way we
can
prevent ourselves from getting our
brains sucked out by the
evil ways many of us think that that's
right so when we come back
uh more of this edition of star talk we
were talking about proofing einstein
right
we're going to go straight to our cosmic
query's version of that
when we return we're back star talk
proving einstein right
chuck thanks for being there as always
pleasure always a pleasure
and we got sylvester jim gates a long
time
friend and colleague who's an einstein
expert a theoretical physics
expert he's all the kind of expert you
need for this
absolutely for this incarnation of star
talk
and we're going to devote this segment
to cosmic queries
uh jim your your presence on our show
was announced to our fan base
and they got completely excited by this
prospect
and so so i i have five pers no
i have three percent overlap with jim's
expertise in the subject
so if i can find a three percent way to
add
i will but basically this is all going
to gym okay so
chuck excellent and do it not not that
it needs to be
said but i have zero percent overlap
with jim
which is why i'm reading the question so
here we go
let's start you know what before we
start let me just
quickly can you um professor
give us a quick breakdown between the
special
and the general when it comes to
relativity i think that might be a nice
framework for anybody who didn't ask a
question
to be a part good thank you chuck so
let me start with special because it's
simpler um
you know if you were standing by a road
and there was a car that was speeding
towards you with its horn blaring
what would you actually hear it would go
something like
right right because you hear that dip in
the tone
that's going to sounded like you were
dying i was going to say uh
yeah no i could do better than that here
you go right no
okay okay so we'll go let's work with
that
nothing's dying we'll work with the cats
now
in his spare time neil does sound
effects for warner brothers
and so so but so the point is that
effect
is because sound changes its
frequency if you're if it's moving
towards you that's when it's high
pitched
or but if it's moving away from you this
pitch goes down
no exactly so
so the point is light actually does the
same thing
when a light source is coming towards
you it appears to be
bluer than it actually is when it's
moving away from you it is appearing to
be redder
and that is one of the primary effects
of special relativity
it's about the relative motion of you
and the source
of the light in the theory of special
relativity
and my car analogy it's this the motion
of the car
either towards or with you so that's
what special relativity is all about is
if i'm moving and you're not how do i
perceive things how do you perceive
things that's the simplest
that's my five-minute class on special
relativity
and so and then general no general
relatives and you juxtapose that against
the general
and the distribution of mass and all
that stuff so the general theory of
relativity is something
very very very different and
what the general theory of relativity is
about is
what is gravity you see in the special
relativity
einstein wasn't thinking about gravity
he was just thinking about how things
would look if i'm moving
but in the general theory of relativity
theory of relativity the question is
what actually
is gravity it's a very deep question
that even sir isaac newton didn't get
the answer to
and the answer that einstein teaches us
through his mathematical wizardry
is that gravity is the space which we
move through and time which we
experience
uh durations in are combines
this like thing he called space-time and
gravity is the bending of this thing so
that's my short course on generality
cool you know there you go all right
that was great that was great okay let's
go to izzy rohr
who says but is this patreon do we do
patreon people first
uh yes sir thank you um yes we always
start with a patreon question because
patreon people give us money so
and for that we are grateful and we show
our gratitude by giving you special
preference
preference wait wait so wait wait but
chuck
yeah we're just like congress we're just
like your congressman
but chuck this just in apparently all
your questions are patreon questions i
have just learned
oh excellent this just in this just
happened every single one of them so
guess what all of you
so thank you to all of you izzy rohr
neil chuck jim
this is your friend violetta the
astrophysics loving kid here in
birmingham alabama
my mom oh you know her okay cool
excellent my mom and i have many
discussions have had many discussions
about this
scientists like to describe einstein's
general relativity
as being incompatible with quantum
mechanics they say things like
they mathematically don't work out
uh or don't work together so our
question is
why the heck is that so yeah jim
yeah what what's up with that okay so
let me give you a second here because i
got to
phrase this without the mathematics
so the idea that is so funny by the way
okay let me just say
that may have been the most physics
thing i've heard
in a very long time i've i've got to
figure out a way to say this
without the mathematics well you see
i don't know if you spoke it's like i'm
sorry me no speak english me speak
mathematics
let me speak well
you may not know this but neil can tell
you this often at the end of my email
messages i ask forgiveness for spelling
and punctuation errors because
my first language is mathematics
english is my second language so i'm at
a disability when people ask me to talk
listen i've never heard a person
admit a fault that makes you better than
most people
[Laughter]
but it causes me difficulties chuck on
many many occasions
okay okay but okay but back to back to
quantum
back background okay so what essentially
happens
is if you believe the universe is
quantum mechanical
then it forces you to forget about
things like electrons because electrons
we think about as little tiny balls
that's the
classical picture that you're taught and
in fact quantum mechanics says
no that's not the way it works for
electrons you have to think of these
things
that are like more like waves except
when they act like particles
so that's the first thing it gives you
this really weird thing that you have to
give up an idea except
sometimes right right okay so now when
you
so there's a piece of mathematics around
this called schrodinger's equation so
i got to bring that in and it tells you
how to calculate if you're going to
bring up shoulder you got you can't
leave out his cat
exactly so just keep going or that
litter box which hasn't been changed
then god knows how long well
just litter boxes that's what i'm about
to do is litter box
we could also go back to neil's uh
neil's rendition of a car horn as it
approaches you
yeah but anyhow so you have a piece of
mathematics
around giving up the idea of particles
and when you now
give that piece of mathematics up and
try to do gravity you find out
you just get into a total mess that you
cannot calculate answers anymore
that take into account the quantum
behavior and that's the message
so that's the that's the disconnect
there is that schrodinger's equation
once you remove anything does that none
of the gravity stuff works
because wow the way that einstein and
newton and all those folks thought about
gravity
has the idea of particles embedded in it
that's the problem
all right right so all right so uh who's
at the end of the day who's got to give
is it is
gravity gonna bend to quantum physics i
see what you did there
i saw what you did there in the gravity
bins yes
oh you know neil this is actually a very
deep question
or is there a third idea bigger than
both of those that then encloses them
under one umbrella there are
variants of all of everything that
you've just said
there well first of all who's going to
bend there are people who will tell you
that gravity is going to be one that
loses this discussion if i had to bet
i'd lean that way too yeah yeah and
there are a lot of people who believe
that that somehow gravity is going to
have to
give way in uh in some manner there are
other people
who have this third idea approach that
you were talking about neil
and one of those and sort of emblematic
of that
is a discussion that's underway about
information and black holes
i know neil is probably aware of this
but there's this whole discussion about
whether
information is conserved like we say
energy is conserved is information
concern
and if you have a universe with black
holes doesn't that mean that some of the
energy disappears i mean some of the
information disappears
and then you violate a conservation law
so there's a whole big discussion in
theoretical physics it's been a way
underway for over a decade
about black holes and information
confidence
all right so when you talk about
information are
are you referring to because we just
talked about this last week give me one
second please
that when neil was talking about virtual
particles and the evaporation of a black
hole and if i'm not mistaken then
this particle actually materializes on
the outside of the black hole and then
that is what escapes and so
then if that were to happen are you
saying that that somehow messes up this
whole idea of the comp
conservation of information
and chuck you were really paying
attention in that it does seem like this
chuck neal why you think i do this job
man i'm getting a free education
yeah okay so that's what okay that's it
but the point is that
it's in a state of flux we don't know
what the final
scenario is gonna be but many people
like me
uh actually think that string theory
will have something to do with the
resolution
okay so the string people think this
yeah well it's not just string people i
think
uh i i don't consider myself a string
person for example i
am someone who spent their life working
on super symmetry and strings happen to
intersect that
okay well i consider myself a string
cheese person
so string cheese yes that's about as
close as i'm getting to it
all right cool all right next one here
we go this is paul
vogel who says recently
between the detection of gravitational
waves and
a photo of an event horizon of a black
hole
some significant predictions made by
einstein's general relativity have been
verified what's the next big prediction
made by general relativity that
scientists are testing
thank you so that's a great question and
it's a great question and the answer is
the following
in 1905 one of einstein wrote four
papers
among those four papers is one
that points out that
energy has to be quantized now we know
that einstein doesn't like quantum
theory but in fact he's one of the
fathers of quantum theory because of
this
1905 paper on the photoelectric effect
that just to be clear he didn't like it
because he didn't think the universe
should be probabilistic right that's
exactly right he wanted determinism as
well whereas okay as quantum mechanics
says no you can't have determinism you
have to
go with probabilities so the answer your
question chuck
is now that we have seen waves of
gravity we want to see the quantization
of the energy
carried by those waves because when we
do that
we will have the star trek graviton yes
in our universe so the same way we know
light has a particle are you saying that
gravity has particle or
wait a minute it would it would have to
be that we find this gravity particle
that's correct and that's the next big
prediction that
that i want to find from uh the kind of
experiments watching graduates you want
to
be able to see the quantization of the
energy that the gravity waves hold that
tells you that gravitons just like you
hear in star trek you know you
always talk about graviton waves at that
point it is no longer science fiction
it's a piece of science wait and chuck
just to follow
your line so a photon is a particle of
light
but you can also speak of light as waves
right right so
that so that is a proper analogy we've
measured
gravitational waves now we want to
measure the gravitational particle
oh my god you have a photon then you
have the graviton so so
so i i don't know any experiments out
there to measure a graviton is this
there aren't
right in the works no nothing to my
knowledge neil i don't
know anyone who's it's this is gonna
have to be an exquisite experiment and
we're just at the stage of
just being able to see the gravity waves
so uh you know is it 50 years is 100
years i don't know
but as our technology improves someone
is eventually going to figure out how to
do that detection
and then we can stop saying that captain
kirk is the only only guy who gets to
talk about gravitons
so if just a quick question if we have
gravitons
then gravity being the curvature of
space and time has no meaning
in the presence of a graviton ah you're
following along here for a lot of people
the detection of a graviton will
likely necessitate a real rethinking of
what
of what gravity is i've already i mean
some of us already are
there uh i don't actually think about
gravity in terms of geometry
it's feel theory that's the tool for
people
all right so what you're saying is
einstein's curved space happens to be a
convenience in certain under certain
situations
that get you the right answer yes and
you're good with that but it's not the
total story
nope okay wow there you go okay
yeah that is so just let the record show
chuck that
jim gates just said einstein had his
head up his ass
just said that just to make it clear
that's funny okay james is sad
james like i'm not saying that i'm not i
didn't say it's like i'm not saying that
the professor's like send your letters
to neil because i did not say that
okay all right actually we got to take a
break and when we come back we'll go out
to our third and final segment of cosmic
queries
uh proving einstein right on star talk
we're back star talk proving einstein
right and chuck is helping me you know
and his
because he's you're a big fan of special
general relativity aren't you check
oh without a doubt are you kidding me
come on man yeah yeah of course
i mean but of course some people like
reality tv i like relativity
okay that didn't work no that did so did
not work but anyhow
but you're on social media what's your
best place people can find you on social
media
at chuck nice comic thank you sir
appreciate a nice comic and you even
have a i stumbled on this you never told
me this i stumbled on one of your
you have a ted talk on technology in the
future
i do technology and the unintended
consequences of human interactions
yeah or the absence of human interaction
by technology yes i stumbled on that i
just i'm angry with you for not telling
me in advance about that because
i can find that on my own uh we've got
jim gates an expert
in theoretical physics jim do you have a
social media platform
i do it's uh dr jim gates uh
you can see there's a twitter what
version and a facebook version but it's
doctor it's just dr i present dr yeah
all right well we'll find you there
and you've got this book proving
einstein right yes
and uh co-authored with kathy pelletier
yeah yeah so uh we're continuing our
cosmic queries
and just before we begin and chuck
before you read one in
uh jim you've got a background there
that looks it looks kind of spacey
actually but then not quite
yeah so could you give us a minute on
that sure so uh
i'm in the odd position deal where it
looks like both of my
twin children are going to become
physicists so this is
you know this is not something i set out
to do but uh
yeah right yeah yeah keep telling
yourself that okay
uh so my daughter works with black holes
and so she's actually
actually started publishing and i
actually had a chance to watch her give
a talk this week so
you know big props to my daughter her
name is delilah but i also got to give
big props to my son
the background that you're looking at
these green little splotches
are artificial neurons that he's been
growing in the laboratory because it
looks like he's going to be
a biophysicist wow as a host okay chuck
he's
he's he's creating the next generation
superhero or superhero villain
yeah without a doubt black holes and
growing neurons
so that's it so that's it right the
daughter will harness the power of the
black hole and the sun
will imbue some some being with that
with that power to rule the world
i've never heard of have you ever
worried about dark side
the dark side there it is there it is
who knows
jim is breeding the dark side so this so
this is
a is it an actual photo or it looks like
it's like no no it looks like our
this is actual photo of uh some of the
first
uh successful cell lines that he's been
growing that where you can see the
evidence that they're developing a
ganglia like
uh real breaks wow sweet man okay wow
that's amazing well watch that space
that's so important okay cool all right
let's get to the next question
chuck yeah bit brain stuff going on in
that family
all right here we go let's um let's go
to
uh let's go to lisa hansen
and she says hello to you all from the
bay area string theories are so
involved and fascinating i love trying
to wrap my brain around them i'm
wondering
what if any other scientific disciplines
are involved
in the research for as a evidence and
proof of these theories
what those clues might be well
yeah clues in this real universe jim and
yeah imagine one
i know he was going to say that
interesting that that question came up
because
just last summer i
did something for the first time in my
life because i tell people i exist at
the boundary of mathematics
and physics so i'm a fallen
mathematician
in some sense but last summer i
published a paper
along with my colleague stefan alexander
here at brown university
evan mcdonough who was one of our
postdocs
and my postdoc constantino scripture
life is as well as our graduate student
leah jenks
and in this paper we set out
a premise that strings
might be able to write structures create
structures
that could potentially be observed in
the cosmic microwave background
we call these structures susie reels
they're like these funny patterns
i hope uh people are familiar with the
cmb it's this
microwave radiation that you can detect
uh by looking out the universe
and what we showed in our paper is if
you
take string the ideas of string theory
seriously they have a way of writing
a kind of signature in this structure so
what kind of science do you need you
need to be an astrophysicist someone who
could actually
look in microwaves at how the universe
uh
gives us a perspective once again it
comes down to the astrophysicist
there you go of course absolutely i
started look
all right now wait i find needed
astronomers
right spring theory may well need
astrophysicists
so that begs the question in
that collaboration who was batman and
who was robin
just a quick thing if i remember stefan
alexander isn't he he's the jazz
musician isn't that cool
that's exactly right stefan is a
professional level
jazz musician although he is a physicist
on faculty here at brown university i
should have said that differently he's
also a jazz musician so he wrote that
book the jazz of physics or the physics
of jazz or something
physics is this yeah okay all right cool
cool man all right
great stuff that's great stuff i don't
let's move on to josh b
who says who has more impressive
mustache
albert einstein or neil degrasse tyson
[Laughter]
do you know i gotta say anytime i'm on i
i got to show up in a movie or in a
documentary
and they put you in hair and makeup you
know and so they do the makeup fine
and then they get to the hair and they
say um can we trim your eyebrows a
little and can we get some of the loose
hairs out of your mustache
i'm saying wait this is my einstein look
you did not
you want to be all trimmed and manscaped
you need a wiry unkempt just wild
mustache yes so what's with that look
jim that einstein sported
so i'm not sure what the question is
[Laughter]
you know what with with that is the
answer we should just move on
that was hilarious let's just go to sam
o'neill
okay who says well by the way just about
eight years ago i just want you to know
i was nominated for the mustache hall of
fame
just so you know just so you know okay
okay well
i'm going to return that i was once
inducted into the luxurious
hair association that's a thing
it was at the time okay
okay here we go this is from sam o'neil
he says
hey dr tyson hey dr gates what's up
chuck my question is
what do you theorize that the strings in
super
string theory are made of
love you guys i would give you money and
i do
samantha from earth from earth
[Laughter]
on this side of that phone okay okay
someone's got to explain that to me you
know there you go uh
well that's all you jim so go for it
yeah yeah so
the thing about string theory which
perhaps isn't completely understood
is that we don't think strings are made
of anything
they are the fundamental thing if it's a
correct picture of the universe
they are the thing everything else is
made of that's right so
therefore you can't say what it's made
of because it is the thing that
everything's made of
that's all we know wow that that feels
like a cop out there i was about to say
that's a little circular
yeah but that's slightly circular just a
little bit
no no chuck you're right but you see one
of the weird things about mathematics
is that you have to take some things on
faith
there's actually a mathematical theorem
that says this
it's called the one of garth's theorems
and so this is one of the really weird
things about math that people do not
appreciate
well no jim be fair it's not that you
have to take it on faith is that you
have to
assert that it's true and if you assert
that it's true then everything else
works
right it's an assertion it's not gee i
hope it's no you just
declare that it's true and then take
everything from there right but you
can't prove
you can't prove the thing that you
assert that's true that's nice
therefore it's an element of faith i
don't i don't i use faith in a different
i know i know you do we have to have
another discussion about the whole faith
we'll get you
i said i'll get you back seven other
ways
to resolve here if only george michael
were here to settle this debate
okay sorry pop culture reference
shouldn't have bought it
here we go since 1980 i know i know
damn chuck i can't help you how old are
you i
am he looks young does that mean he does
he just
he's he's that oil of old age
of old age that's not exactly what he
said
okay i've never heard that before i like
that i heard that from an old friend of
mine said
oil of old age i like it all right here
we go
uh this is woody he says after seeing
neil's enthusiastic response what are
jim's thoughts on a
cosmic gravitational background you just
talked about the
cosmic microwave background and string
being able to be visible in that
what about a cosmic gravitational
background
do you have so this would be this would
be the the paw print of the birth of the
universe
expressed in gravitational waves right
right would be and
i don't see i've never actually heard a
scientific
discussion of this but that idea
it really seems well grounded that one
hit a mat
no that if one could i mean
look the cosmic microwave background is
an electromagnetic
background it's microwaves right right
just like the microwaves you cook it's
light it's like
it's a form of light right but uh but a
gravitational background a gravitational
signature from the big bang
i don't see any reason why that's not
possible i've not heard of any
scientific discussions of the concept
out okay so part of why the
the cosmic microwave background is so
useful to us
not only that it exists but we have a
map a very detailed map of its structure
and right now when we're detecting
gravitational waves oh something
happened we think over in that direction
of the sky
you know we don't we have nowhere near
the the mapping precision
to possibly do anything interesting yet
and i don't know when
it would come oh i would give us about
20 to 30 years because
but in order to do what you're saying
neil first of all we have to get a
sufficient number of gravity wave
detectors right
now there are about four in the world
that are one there's one for example
in europe there's one in australia
and there are two in the us so that's
the minimum number you need to do the
mapping
and they're not all sort of up fully
functional so
we got some time right and then you need
then you want to get
uh gravitational waves of different
wavelengths
right and so that so it's not just this
one that came through get the whole
spectrum if i can borrow that word from
light and
then you have this two dimensions of
information
exactly to interpret so yeah so
yeah it's we're not there yet but if we
were there it would tell us a whole lot
about the very first moments of the go
exactly
and that's where science is pushing
toward cool yeah that is
super super cool all right roman
precup or pre-cop says this
is it possible that some of the stars
observed in the night sky
are duplicated or multiply
duplicated due to light bending and
gravitational fields of a
massive object like super like some
super black hole
i should let neil yeah i could take that
go ahead neil
yeah i could take that one so the answer
is yes
next question no so what happens is that
the way this
unfolds um by the way einstein first
predicted that you could make a ring
called einstein ring where
the light would bend symmetrically in
all directions around a single object
and create a ring of light
from that single object from behind it
turns out that's not realistic because
that that requires exact
lineup right so that there's a perfect
geometry
of all sight lines that go around most
things don't line up exactly but when we
do find them
sort of line up even if not exactly you
find distortions that resemble rings
the arcs right they don't make a full
ring but they make arcs
now if you have one object behind that
object will make
a minimum of three images one that comes
straight through
and then two that come around the side
and up from there it can make three
five or seven images so yes right in
fact
something cool is i'm cool you ready
ready okay so
we found we found objects quasars whose
light bent around
gravity uh galaxy clusters that were
sort of midway
right from the from einstein's gravity
and
but the path lengths were not the same
okay so this this the path on one side
is a little longer than the path than
the other now you know how we know
because quasars
vary they have explosions the light
varies
so we see it and it varies up here
and then a scheduled time later it
varies over in exactly the same way
so you get to see the same thing twice
that's because of the change in
intensity of light due to the explosion
is that what's happening well no there's
things go yeah the
quasars can eat things right
episodically a lot of
weird things episode of things that can
happen in quasars but the fact that you
have two different path lengths
is extraordinary testing of the shape of
the curvature of space
and how much gravity is in the cluster
and how far away
the quasar is so it's an amazing it's an
amazing thing
it's funny to me that you've come back
to this because this is what my daughter
works on we talked about the cells
behind me
but when you have rings of matter around
rotating black holes chuck he's just
giving equal time here
i know
but when you have rings of matter that
glow around spinning black holes you can
actually see the back side of the ring
because the gravity bends the light from
the little girl
that's what a daughter works on yeah
that's very cool man
one last quick one and we'll uh and we
got to call we we
we're over two we're done with it yeah
chuck go ahead uh this is from glenn
he says dr gates
do you think that white holes exist
was einstein observing gave uh
what was einstein observing that gave
him the impression
that they did all right now i'm just
going to answer this for you
no there are no white holes einstein was
a racist like everybody else back at
that time
and i just couldn't let it be just
started off truck couldn't just let it
be a black hole could you okay
yeah so go ahead
you know what i love here's what i love
about the professor he's sitting there
like i have nothing to do with this
whatever chuck is saying right now
that's his crazy business i only just
met chuck
exactly i don't know this man
all right go ahead sorry okay so let's
make it quick jimmy yeah so what's
really quick
what's really interesting is black holes
aren't black it turns out that because
of stephen hawking
we know that they actually have this
very slight radiation called
hawking radiation so they're not exactly
black
that went out a long time ago so you
know got to keep up with the news in
physics
okay but the white hole the concept the
white hole concept
i i people who
look i don't know any solid scientific
arguments about the existence of such
things
i have not encountered okay and folks we
don't see anything in the universe
that will resemble what a white hole
would be predicted to be which would be
the mathematical opposite of a black
hole right right so everything is
spewing out and that should look like
something
in the signature of life there's nothing
spectacular
yeah yeah but we really gotta cut it
there jim
okay we gotta get you back for nine
other subjects that's okay neil okay we
got you
we got you on the roller derby i got
game all right and we'll get a picture
from your other child's
behind you on the next program okay
black holes
man black hole
always good to have you always a
pleasure all right this has been star
talk
was einstein right proving einstein
right edition
i'm neil degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist as always
keep looking
you